trois graines de champions comme lucas
pouille le pensionnaire du pôle france
de poitiers
il est revenu la semaine dernière de
roland garros avec le titre de champion
de france d'avoir gagné ça me met en
confiance pour venir ici
du coup pour l'équipe c'est bien au
début personne s'intéresse à toi extrait
après tu fais un bon résultat donc il ya
beaucoup de monde qui s'intéresse qu'à
commencer sur le toit c'est bien le plus
important
mais bon maintenant les bus de cfa taux
de trop gérer ça et maintenant ça va
mieux c'est comme c'est comme s'ils
étaient à vendre comme avant mais pas
comme tout le monde champion de tennis a
14 ans et trois heures d'entraînement
par jour et 3 heures de cours
déjà les prémices du circuit bref être
pro avant de passer pro un sacré rythme
pour ceux qui suivent les traces de
gasquet et tsonga
révélé en leur temps par là-même copa
del sol sur prêts destinés à devenir des
joueurs d'avenir mais sur la route et et
demandant qu'est ce que nous on sait que
les joueurs à maturité en france offrant
sortir 20 ans 19 ans maintenant type les
gasquet et monfils et tsonga
et encore on espère maintenant on leur
donne les moyens de réussir aussi bien
sur le pôle de boulot risque sur le pôle
de poitiers l'an dernier les français
s'étaient imposés à saintes s'il
renouvelle demain ils disputeront la
finale de la copa del sol le week-end
prochain en espagne
[Musique]